alors y en a quelques-uns parmi vous qui
m'ont demandé d'aller plus loin dans les
mathématiques de la relativité générale
et je dois bien dire que ça me démange
un petit peu de ne pas vous parler de
danseurs du coup on va essayer d'aller
un peu plus loin aujourd'hui mais du
coup ça va pas être un truc très
compréhensible par tout le monde ça peut
être un truc grand public et en
particulier si vous n'avez jamais appris
la relativité générale de façon enfin le
soulager le prix de court de relativité
générale
je vous conseille très très très
fortement de revoir quasiment toutes mes
vidéos que j'ai fait jusque là jusqu'à
ce sur la relativité générale si on a
juste quelques uns à voir il dirait que
le 5 et le 7 sont très importants le 9
le 11 et le 12 aussi mais surtout bien
sûr les plus importants sont les 17 18
et 19 surtout à les voir là 19
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses que je
dis dans ces vidéos qui ne correspondent
pas du tout à la vulgarisation classique
de relativité générale et pour cause
puisque la vulgarisation classique de la
relativité générale ne permet pas de
comprendre la relativité générale tout
cas selon moi mais je préfère aussi vous
prévenir
il ne suffit pas d'avoir vu ces vidéos
pour comprendre la vidéo qui vient va
falloir aussi une certaine aisance avec
des concepts mathématiques je tiens à
insister sur le fait que ce que je vais
présenter ici n'est absolument pas un
cours en fait ce que je vais faire c'est
insisté sur l'intuition qu'il faut avoir
derrière ces objets mathématiques de la
relativité générale mais je ne vais
jamais définir formellement ces objets
cours mathématiques que l'on va
manipuler et pour cause parce que pour
introduire vraiment ces objets
mathématiques faudrait parler de
connexion lévy civitas il faudrait
vraiment des désordres et des heures à
passer à réfléchir à pas mal de concepts
mathématiques fondamentaux pour en
arriver vraiment objet de la relativité
générale
du coup ce que je vais dire aujourd'hui
va être encore très intuitif et du coup
il ya beaucoup de choses que je vais
dire qu'ils sont en fait fausse ceci dit
je pense que ce que je vais dire qui va
être une sorte de vision globale du de
l'ensemble des objets mathématiques
nécessaire pour comprendre la relativité
générale je pense que tout ce que je
vais dire va être peut-être vraiment
extrêmement utile à ceux qui veulent
vraiment apprendre et comprendre leur la
relativité générale en tout cas ce que
je veux dire c'est le truc que j'aurais
aimé
qu'on me dise lorsque j'ai commencé à
lire le court dericquebourg moulant sur
la relativité générale alors l'objet le
plus important d'études de la relativité
générale c'est comme j'ai pas mal incité
à tuer dans l'épisode 18 c'est la
courbure de l'espace temps
alors cette courbure de l'espace temps
c'est un truc qui est très compliqué
lors dimension 2 c'est relativement
simple quand elle apparaît dans un
épisode 11 et 12 ou en gros on peut
résumer toute la courbure de l'espace
temps à l'aide d'un seul nombre qui va
être les courbures et si elle est
positive alors les lignes droites ont
tendance à se rapprocher si elle est
négative elles ont tendance à s'éloigner
en relativité générale on se passe dans
un espace temps des dimensions 4 et à ce
moment là la courbure peut différer déjà
d'un point à l'autre parce qu'on ne va
pas forcément considère des géométries
qui sont soit homogène on peut avoir des
géométries qui sont non homogène et
c'est le cas en pratique en relativité
générale surtout lorsqu'on utilise par
exemple à terre mais aussi la courbure
de l'espace-temps peut varier d'une
direction à l'autre et on va voir aussi
que c'est le cas est la cover de
l'espace-temps peut ainsi différer selon
qu'on mette les deux pommes comme ça du
coup leur trajectoire espace-temps fait
bon se rapprocher doucement mais l'aimé
comme ça quelqu'un hors trajectoire dans
l'espace-temps d'importance à s'éloigner
on va voir ça
tout à l'heure mais donc du coup pour
décrire la courbure de l'espace-temps va
nous falloir utiliser beaucoup plus de
nombres qui décrivent cette courbure et
en fait ça correspond à un objet
mathématique qu'on appelle le temps
soeur de riemann qui est l'objet le plus
important de toute la théorie selon moi
en grelottant soeur de riemann il va
nous dire si on prend de droit qui sont
leurs parallèle il va nous dire s'ils
ont tendance à se rapprocher ou à
s'éloigner en fait il nous dit plus que
ça mais on peut partir de là pour
commencer
donc on considère de droite qui sont
initialement en parallèle et la question
qu'on se pose c'est à ce qu'elles vont
plutôt se rapprocher ou s'éloigner pour
mathématisée ça va nous falloir
introduire quelques notations
on va appeler vais le vecteur directeur
de ces deux droites et u
l'écartement entre ces deux droites donc
techniquement en fait qui s'est passé
c'est qu'on prend un vecteur v directeur
d'une droite et un point donné et on le
transporte parallèlement selon hu et
faut aussi dire que pour que tout ce
raisonnement
il faut en fait supposer que uvb sont
très très très petit à petit par rapport
à quoi petit par rapport à la courbure
de l'espace temps d'un point une formule
en fait ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
considère des vecteurs qui sont
infinitésimaux mais on pratique ça ça
marche si ces vecteurs là sont justes
petit devant la courbure ok donc
maintenant ce qu'on va faire si on va
voir comment lorsque l'on se déplace le
nom de ces lignes droites les vecteurs
vont être modifiés et donc pour ça on va
prendre un vecteur initial w qu'on va
copier en le transportant parallèlement
en eau est donc ici à l'instant initial
on peut dire que ces deux vecteurs w
sont en gros les mêmes plats typiquement
je viens de dire un truc faux mais c'est
utile de penser que c'est vrai et
ensuite on va faire c'est qu'on va
transporter parallèlement le long des
lignes droites ce vecteur w et on va
voir si après un petit chemin après
avoir parcouru la distance donnée par le
vecteur v on va se demander si le
vecteur des vecteurs w qu'on obtient
sont mêmes en fait en général s'il ya
une courbure les deux vecteurs w peuvent
ne pas être les mêmes ou quelqu'un on va
s'intéresser à ce moment-là à leurs
différences alors donc cet écartement
qu'on obtient ici c'est ce qu'on appelle
le temps third au ryman appliqué à uv w
et on le note souvent eyrieux devait
appliquer à w mais faut savoir qu'en
fait c'est une application qui est très
linéaire en uv et w et donc là vous
imaginez la question varie lui vw on
obtient des valeurs différentes du
vecteur est arrivé de w
ceci dit arriver de w c'est encore un
vecteur et donc si on veut calculer des
valeurs numériques de ce vecteur parce
qu'on doit faire c'est projeté ce
vecteur sur un ensemble de coordonner et
du coup ce que l'on fait lorsqu'on fait
des calculs de relativité générale c'est
qu'on projette à chaque fois ce vecteur
est projeté ce vecteur ça correspond à
dire qu'on prend une forme linéaire et
qu'on l'appliqué ce vecteur de façon
donc la plus générale possible le temps
soeur de riemann c'est une application
quadri linéaire qui prend en compte
trois vecteurs et une forme linéaire
pour nous donner un
réel alors là vous êtes peut-être
complètement perdus du coup on va
simplifier un petit peu et je vais
m'intéresser uniquement à la manière
dont ces deux lignes droites se
rapprochent ou s'éloignent et pour ça on
va s'intéresser à la manière dont le
vecteur directeur v évolué autrement dit
on va s'intéresser aux vecteurs est
arrivée appliqué avait si les lignes
droites ont tendance à se rapprocher est
relevé va aller en gros dans le même
sens que le vecteur eu alors que si les
lignes droites ont tendance à s'éloigner
à ce moment là est relevé appliqués
avaient veut avoir une direction opposée
a eu donc pour mesurer sa tout ce qu'on
a à faire en fait c'est prendre le
produit scalaires entre r u v de v est
le vecteur plus si la valeur de ce
produit scalaires va nous donner non
seulement le signe de la courbure ce qui
est positif ou négatif donc positif si
ça se rapproche et négatives 6 et
s'éloigne et en plus ça va nous donner
une distance caractéristiques pour
commencer à observer ce genre de
phénomène alors je sais que jusque-là
salaires encore très abstrait mais en
fait c'est exactement ce genre de
courbure de produits scolaires qui va
nous permettre de dire s'il appelait
paul ont tendance à s'éloigner ou à se
rapprocher
mais pour cela il va falloir que je vous
parle de la solution de choix chill qui
est une solution aux équations
d'einstein qui correspond au cas où on a
une masse centrale seuls dans l'univers
typiquement lorsque ajuste la terre et
qu'on met de liste ou les effets des de
la lune et du soleil ils font part de
tous qui a d'autres pour décrire la
solution de choix chill il nous faut
parler d'un espace-temps qui pour le
coup va être vraiment courbes et de
dimensions cad donc ça peut paraître
très compliqué en fait ce que l'on fait
pour représenter ou étudier
mathématiquement mais faire des calculs
par rapport à cet espace-temps de
schwarzschild pour y arriver on utilise
une carte de l'espace-temps deux
dimensions 4 et quand je parle de cartes
je fais vraiment référence à la
de mercator qu'une carte plane donc dans
le plan et lydien deux dimensions de
d'un objet qui est une courbure non
planes qui la terre je maîtrise ferrique
et dans la carte mercator
on a déjà parlé les lignes droites ne
sont plus dessiné de façon droite est
long elle apparaît courbe sur la carte
mais encore une fois dans l'espace
le vrai espace qu'est la terre ses
lignes sont vraiment droite dire que si
on les suivait sur terre on aurait
vraiment l'impression de marcher droit
de la même façon les lignes droites de
l'espace-temps des géodésique et je
décide de l'espace-temps sont
parfaitement droites dans l'espace
tension suivait ces jo des ide dans
l'espace temps on irait tout droit tout
droit dans l'espace temps ça veut dire
vitesse constante sans accélération mais
sur la carte qu'on va utiliser pour
représenter l'espace temps de dimensions
4 en présence d'une masse centrale les
trajectoires que l'on va dessiner ne
vont pas paraître droite mais c'est
juste parce qu'on les dessine sur une
carte dans le vrai espace temps ces
lignes droites sont droites
alors ça veut dire quoi utiliser une
carte ça veut dire que par exemple si on
prend un quart de mercator les échelles
de la carte vont différer selon le lieu
là on est sur la carte pour vérifier ça
je vous invite à utiliser google maps
vous zoomez sur l'équateur et puis vous
montez sans faire de scroll donc sans
dézoomer jusqu'au pôle nord et là vous
allez voir en bas à droite à l'échelle
de la carte qui varie donc les échelles
sur la carte mercator ci ont dessiné des
petits répond repères qui font un
kilomètre de côté c'est petit repère
différerait selon là on est sur la carte
est ce qu'on va faire pour représenter
l'espace temps de schwarzschild c'est la
même chose c'est à dire qu'on va
dessiner des petits repères un peu
partout dans l'espace temps dans la
longueur des vecteurs de base va
différer d'un point de l'espace temps à
l'autre alors les coordonnées qui sont
utilisés dans l'espace de schwarzschild
sont les coordonnées ferrique avec une
corde est d'autant plus donc tu es
pourra coordonnées de temps rt ta fille
info faire un petit peu attention
lorsque j'ai cryptée ici tu n' a pas
forcément de sens physique où il se
trouve que dans le cas de
l'espace temps de schild la carte qu'on
utilise correspond à une valeur de tai
chi dont on peut donner un sens physique
ça correspond au temps observé par un
observateur qui est très très loin de la
masse central de la même façon air ici
ne correspond pas vraiment à la distance
par rapport au centre et en fait ça ne
correspond pas la distance par rapport
au centre air tout comme tu es et
uniquement là coordonnées d'un point tel
qu'on représente ce point dans la carte
donc c'est pas la coordonnée absolue
d'un point dans l'espace-temps saissac
ordonnée lorsqu'on représente l'espace
temps dans la carte sim maintenant on
représente juste la partie de la carte
qui est dans un plan de la carte vous
donne vraiment les dents une carte ici
on considérer que air et la distance par
rapport à l'origine dans la carte et on
va considérer que teva être la hauteur
on va aussi considérer s'il que l'ongle
teta l'angle par rapport à une certaine
direction donc là ce que je représente
est là c'est une carte de dimension 3 et
qui manque une coordonnées ou appeler
fille qui correspond à des trucs n'est
pas dans le plan des spas ce que j'ai
considéré au début
en fait comme en théorie newtonienne on
peut toujours se placer dans un seul
plan pour étudier le problème si bien
que l'on réduit tout le problème on
dimension4 à un problème en dimension 3
et donc au niveau des différents points
de la carte les repères que l'on va
dessiner ne vont pas être les mêmes
en fait si on se place tout près de la
masse centrale le vecteur selon le temps
va être plus longue que dans lorsqu'on
est loin le vecteur sûrement air lui va
être plus court que si on est loin et le
vecteur selon état va être plus grand
lorsque l'on est prêt et plus petits
lorsqu'on est loin
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ses
repères qui sont différents si on
considère par exemple le vecteur selon
péta le fait qu'ils soient si grand
lorsqu'on soit proche du soleil veut
dire qu'il faut un grand-angle teta pour
parcourir une distance de un mètre alors
corse qu on en est très loin il suffit
d'un tout petit anglet état pour
parcourir une distance de remettre de la
même façon le fait que le vecteur de
temps soit civile long lorsqu'on est
proche du centre de
de la masse centrale ça veut dire que si
on considère une seconde qui passe
lorsqu'on est proche de la masse ça
correspond à parcourir beaucoup de
distance dans la carte tout cas beaucoup
plus que si on passait une seconde très
très loin et ça ça reflète la dilatation
gravitationnelle alors plutôt que de
dessiner à la main des petits repères un
peu partout ce qu'on fait en pratique
lorsqu'on étudie la théorie de la
relativité générale c'est considérer ce
qu'on appelle un tenseur métriques noté
geemu geemu si on l'appliquera des x men
et x nu donc je vais faire un peu
passées sur le pourquoi de ces notations
messala correspondent notamment à des
produits tant sur elf des trucs assez
compliqué mais dans ce cas on peut
l'écrire plus simplement comme étant
égal à cette expression qui est la
métrique de schwarz
donc si on pense si on y réfléchit
vraiment la métrique de choir seals ça
correspond vraiment juste à dessiner des
repères partout dans un bain dans une
carte de l'espace temps et les
coordonnées ici les valeurs qu'on a
devant les détails les d'été car et
l'ailière carré tout ça ça correspond
vraiment la longueur des repères que
j'ai dessiné sur le dessin précédent
plus exactement la longueur des repères
que j'ai dessiné peut être linverse du
coefficient qu'il est devant chacun des
trucs alors dans cette expression vous
voyez à un terme hier par est requis et
rs qui est ce qu'on appelle le rayon de
choir shield donc je vais en reparler
beaucoup plus en détail quand on parlera
des trous noirs mais dans notre cas pour
l'instant aujourd'hui on peut tout
simplement considéré que rs était égal à
2 g m / c'est carré donc pour la terre
son calcul ça avec la masse de la terre
à la place de m ça nous fait 9 mm vous
pouvez voir que cette expression là elle
est mal défini si on prend une valeur de
air de la distance par rapport à
l'origine sur la carte
si on prend une valeur d air qui est
plus petit que le rayon de schwarzschild
cette expression là est mal définie ça
c'est ce que ça correspond à ce qu'on
appelle une singularité de coordonnées
qui est très liée à l'existence des
trous noirs et en particulier à
l'horizon des événements mais dans notre
cas aujourd'hui on va considérer bien
sûr des valeurs 2
art qui seront plus de l'ordre du rayon
de la terre comme lorient de la terre
c'est 6400 km les valeurs de petite
terre que l'on va considérer vont donc
être beaucoup beaucoup plus grande que
le rayon de change il de la terre ok
c'est bon on a notre carte de l'espace
temps maintenant ce qui va nous
intéresser c'est bien sûr de prédire des
trajectoires dans le vrai espace temps
et pour ce faire ce qu'on va faire c'est
on va les dessiner sur la carte
et c'est là que les lignes droites qui
sont droit dans le vrai ce prêt ce temps
vont paraître courbé sur la carte pour
savoir comment ces lignes droites sur la
carte vont être courbé
on peut utiliser le principe de moindre
action sur lequel le patient ça fait une
très bonne vidéo
donc il faut savoir que les géodésique
de l'espace-temps sont des extrêmes
sommes dues lagrangien du coup on plaît
calculé à partir des équations de liens
lagrange
mais bon je vous passe les détails
toujours est-il qu'elle a fini quelqu'un
de bien cette équation qui est
l'équation des géodésique où les
coefficients gamma ici sont ceux qu'on
appelle les symboles de christoffel les
symboles de christoffel que l'on peut
déduire de la métrique qu'on l'utilisé
c'est à dire des repères que l'on a
choisi attentivement si on se souvient
de la carte de mercator les lignes
droites apparaît sur la carte courbée
vers l'intérieur lorsque la courbure est
positive ou lorsqu'on prend une carte
des géométries hyperbolique vers
l'extérieur et si et si dans la mercator
à se courbe vers l'intérieur comme ceci
peut imaginer que les repères que le
considèrent qu'ils sont au niveau des
pôles sont des beaucoup plus grand on a
des vecteurs beaucoup plus grand ça veut
dire que les distances qui sont sur la
carte en fait sont exagérées sont
beaucoup plus grandes que ce qu'ils ne
sont en réalité et du coup pour faire
calculer un peu court chemin entre deux
points on peut il est plus court de
passer par ces partis là où les
distances sont exagérées donc c'est un
peu l'intuition derrière comment on
calcule cette équation là qu'il
corresponde calculer les symboles de
christoffel à partir des variations de
la métrique de gemini et ensuite il
reprend la carte mercator on peut
déduire des lignes droites sur cette
carte
les valeurs des temps soeur de rim à ce
qu'on voit très bien sur cette carte si
les trajectoires ont tendance à se
rapprocher les unes les autres ou à
s'éloigner donc là encore une façon de
formaliser ça je vais sauter les étapes
de calcul d'ailleurs je vous invite à
aller voir le cours de richard taille et
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur les
calculs qui sont derrière tout ça
toujours est il qu'à partir de la
manière dont les trajectoires se courbe
sur une carte
c'est à dire à partir des symboles de
christoffel peut calculer la courbure de
l'espace temps c'est à dire le temps
soeur de riemann donc encore je souhaite
les étapes de calcul mais ça correspond
à cette équation qui est assez dégueu
mais encore une fois qu'on a fini ses
calculs on obtient les coordonnées du
tenseur de riemann donc et toutes ses
coordonnées la globalement on peut
écrire le transfert de riemann air
alfa-beta menu vous remplace alfa-beta
menu par les coordonnées de notre carte
donc par trt taoufik alors on peut se
demander à quoi correspond une valeur de
r alfa beta minute au repos pour
commencer je vais juste rappeler que
cette valeur du temps sur de riemann
dépend du point dans l'espace temps que
l'on considère mais un an pour un donner
de l'espace temps on a un repère qui
associe à ça et bien la valeur de
ce temps soeur dépendre de ce repère
donc des vecteurs du repaire de alpha et
bêta venu et valeur exacte de ce temps
ça va être donné par air de mumu
appliquée aux vecteurs de bêta et on
prend le produit scalaires avec valfort
bon ça ça peut paraître très compliqué
mais là on a vraiment fait un truc de
fou déjà parce que cette expression là
c'est une expression qui est
indépendante de la carte que l'on a
choisi
et là on a vraiment un objet enfin qui
décrit un truc intrinsèque un truc qui
dépend vraiment de l'espace temps en
tant que tel et qui ne dépend pas de la
carte qu'on a choisie pour représenter
cet espace temps enfin c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles le danseur de
riemann est si important alors nous pour
aujourd'hui
comme je le dis on va considérer
essentiellement des produits scalaires
de la forme est arrivé à piquet avait le
tous cas les rues et dans le cas du
tenseur de riemann ça correspond pas mal
de coordonnées du tenseur de riemann
mais ce qui va nous intéresser pour
décrire des trajectoires des objets à
travers l'espace temps c'est bien sûr de
considérer le cas où les trajectoires le
vecteur directeur ici v correspond à un
mouvement à travers le temps du coup on
va replacer le vecteur vais ici par le
vecteur de thé et du coup les
coordonnées qui vont nous intéresser du
tenseur de riemann pour aujourd'hui ça
va être cc3 coordonnées la rrt rpr
tête-à-tête été et m fit éviter alors
pour interpréter ces valeurs là on va
considérer une pomme qui est au dessus
du sol et on va se poser que à
l'instinct initial la pomme ne bouge pas
par rapport au sol ça ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'à travers l'espace temps
les trajectoires de la pomme et du sol à
travers l'espace temps sont initialement
parallèle et non seulement à son
parallèle en plus comme on ne bouge pas
par rapport au centre de la terre le
mouvement de la pomme et du sol vont
être parfaitement selon la direction e&t
c'est à dire vers le futur autrement dit
on va considérer que le vecteur v qu'on
avait dans la formule
m le mouvement à travers le temps c'est
à dire que tu es ensuite le vector lui
qui va être l'écartement entre le sol et
la pomme ça va être le vecteur rue du
sol vers la pomme et ça c'est une
direction qui est radial c'est à dire
qu'il avait aligné avec le centre de la
terre autrement dit le vecteur eu ici
entre le sol et la pomme ça va être tout
simplement er du coup la grande question
de savoir est ce que la pomme va finir
par se rapprocher au fur et à mesure du
temps on va finir par s'éloigner du sol
peut être répondu par la valeur du
tenseur de riemann de ce produit
scalaires là qui est égale à la valeur
du temps sordo riman rr trt alors je
vous épargne les détails de calcul qui
m'ont fait pas mal transpirer mais si je
considère une distance d entre la pomme
et le sol
ça va me dire que la manière dont le sol
est la pomme s'éloigne de l'autre va
être en des fois ce produit scalaires
qui va est égal à moins dé ces carrés rs
/ r x 1 - rs l'horaire et là on peut
faire une application numérique quand on
peut supposer que la pomme est à un
mètre au dessus du sol
si c'est le cas en place des parrains et
on obtient moins six fois dix puissance
moins six mètres par seconde car est
plus important dans cette formule c'est
clairement le signe négatif le signe
négatif nous dit que la courbure de
l'espace temps pour des trajectoires
d'or sens du temps et selon une distance
radial et négatives de l'espace-temps
courbet a tendance à éloigner la pomme
du sol dire ce que j'avais prétendu ceci
dit cette accélération de la pomme par
rapport au sol est incroyablement faible
puisqu'elle est de l'ordre du
millionième de l'accélération du sol
vers le haut donc imperceptible
du coup vous êtes quand même pas mal
menti dans l'épisode 18 quand je dis que
la terre rester proche du soleil cause
de courbure positif de l'espace temps
puisqu'en fait la courbure de l'espace
temps dans la direction du temps avec un
écart selon à distance radial est
négative et du coup s'éloigne plus tôt
le sol de la lune que ça ne le rapproche
du coup on a l'impression qu'il ya une
contradiction le fait que ces coupures à
négative semble indiquer que
planète on va avoir tendance à
s'éloigner du soleil notamment la
question qu'il faut se poser du coup
c'est pourquoi la ce que la terre tourne
quand même autour du soleil alors d'un
côté et à la courbure positive de
l'espace tendances en sorte ou radial
qui a un rôle à jouer mais le plus
important dans tout ça c'est en fait la
courbure positive de l'espace pont à
l'intérieur du soleil ou à l'intérieur
de la terre ils pouvoir expliquer ça bah
je vais devoir revenir l'équation
d'einstein
avant de parler de la courbure
d'einstein je reviens sur la remarque
que j'ai fait c'est en promenant deux
tonnes et qu on les éloigne dans la
direction ortho radial toutes ces terres
qui sont séparés par un certain angle
teta dans la carte sim ou encore une
fois ces pommes ne bouge pas un instant
initial elles ont une trajectoire selon
eux tu es si on considère que la
distance entre les deux est de 1 m par
si on fait les calculs on voit que
l'accélération relative de l'un par
rapport à l'autre
il va être positif c'est à dire qu'ils
vont avoir tendance à se rapprocher avec
une accélération qui va être moitié
d'accélération entre la pomme et le sol
alors est ce que c'est un hasard que ça
soit exactement la moitié en fait non
aussi si je mets peut pas maintenant
avant en arrière comme ça je vais
trouver exactement le résultat a que
comme ça comme ça par symétrie et du
coup en fait j'ai deux directions dans
lesquelles c'est la moitié de ce qu'elle
est dans l'autre direction
ça c'est pas un hasard la somme de ces
courbure forme un objet ultra importante
dans la théorie kahnienne qui est le
temps soeur de richie les danseurs de
richie c'est la somme des courbures sont
différentes directions
lorsqu'on regarde selon un seul vecteur
directeur mais en fait c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça lâche 3,32 décrire
juste et le coefficient diagonaux du
tenseur de régime mais en tout cas on
peut faire la remarque que le temps
soeur de reiki dans le cadre de ce dont
je viens de parler il est nul dans la
direction du temps et pour comprendre ça
va falloir que vous parle de l'équation
d'einstein
alors voici l'équation d'einstein tout
cas celle sans la constante cosmologique
dont je reparlerai dans un prochain
épisode r minutes donc le coefficient du
tenseur de réty - 1/2 fois la trace du
tenseur de richie fois j'ai mis nu doit
être égal à 4 tôt j'ai divisé par ces
puissances quatre fois temu août et
menus va être le temps soeur énergie
impulsion au stress
ne riez comme j'ai pu dire dans
l'épisode 18 c'était un anglicisme
désolé alors ce temps sûreté minul
décrit deux choses d'un côté il va
décrire la manière dont la matière se
déplace à travers l'énergie mais aussi
la manière dont elles se dispersent à
travers l'espace temps cette dispersion
là est caractérisée par ce qu'on appelle
la pression de l'énergie et en gros si
on regardait d'un point de vue
statistique
on a vraiment la moyenne et les
quartiers et donc en particulier nous
ici là on est avec claire et puis même
mon corps en fait on est très peu dense
comparé au centre de la terre en fait
autant citer et très négligeable et en
fait on peut considérer que la surface
de la terre temu est égal à zéro
or si t'es mis nu est égal à zéro
hermine uva est égal à zéro aussi et
donc ça s'explique pourquoi la somme des
courbures à travers le temps est égal à
zéro
mais bien sûr à l'intérieur de la terre
teminé plus négligeable
il prend des valeurs importantes et ça
impose une courbure de richie qui va
être positive donc une moyenne des
courbures qui est positif et donc des
courbures du tenseur de riemann pourrait
être positive et c'est donc les
courbures positive à l'intérieur de la
terre qui d'une certaine manière attire
les autres géodésique vers l'intérieur
de la terre et c'est ça qui fait que le
soleil tourne autour de la terre c'est
pas tellement la courbure de l'espace
temps global puisque cette courbure de
l'espace temps et même négative en
dehors de la terre sur la direction
radial mais c'est surtout la courbure
positif de l'espace temps à l'intérieur
de la terre et du soleil qui font que la
lune tout autour de la terre et que la
terre tourne autour du soleil
voilà c'était l'épisode hardcore
j'espère que vous avez compris quelque
chose que vous avez tiré quelque chose
cet épisode a été vraiment
bon je vais dire des vidéos en trottant
dans les détails mathématiques sur
youtube se déguise pas trop il est
vraiment expérimental et du cou tiens
vraiment à savoir ce que vous en avez
pensé si ça vous a été si vous avez
trouvé ça intéressant non utile ou si
vous n'avez pas aimé en gros je vais pas
refaire ce genre de vidéos donc si vous
avez aimé ce genre de vidéo vraiment
dit-il mois pour aller plus loin encore
une fois je recommande le cours de
richard theillet surtout livres de cours
sur nexity n'a comme figuré que guru
blanc qui est disponible gratuitement
sur le web est d'ailleurs j'aurais merci
beaucoup éric bourgault cas c'est grâce
à lui que je connais la relativité
générale